so yesterday i interviewed ben dixon
host of the benjamin dixon show
and we talked about what could joe biden
focus on next early last week
the rumor was the report was that tax
reform would be next
after covet relief now being done uh
earlier this week we heard it's going to
be a three trillion dollar
infrastructure schools and families
package
which will be next but in the back of
all of this
is the push to expand voting rights and
there's
of i would argue a very strong case to
be made
that the advantage of going next to
voting rights is twofold
number one it's of paramount importance
to win
elections that as many people be able to
vote as possible
and that republicans not be allowed to
succeed with what they are doing
remember that republicans in the
aftermath of the 2020 election
launched proposed wrote are starting to
work on more than 250 different voter
suppression bills
across more than 40 states so not only
is the issue of expanding voting rights
relevant for
winning elections it's of particularly
timely importance because republicans
are trying to do the exact opposite
in addition to this there's the context
of the filibuster now we'll get in a
moment to what is in the voting rights
bill
that the house passed but if you were
thinking as democrats are
we may need to do something with the
filibuster to get things done in the
next two years
with democrats having the white house
house and senate
and it's the filibuster being there that
may prevent us from doing that
is there any better issue over which we
could
justify doing again it's a modification
of the filibuster elimination we don't
know
but what would be a better case to make
than this is about voting republicans
are blocking
voting rights we must do something with
the filibuster so that's the
if you want to make a case for why it
should indeed
be voting rights expansion that should
be focused on first
you could make the case that it's
because republicans
are actively doing the opposite so
democrats must push back against those
250 bills
because if you believe you'll need
filibuster changes to get other things
done
it's probably uh politically more viable
to justify changing the filibuster over
something as important as
like listen you know with guns
i think it would be justified in theory
to modify the filibuster to try to get
things done
but i think from a public relations
standpoint it would be more difficult
with something like we this is voting
rights
you arguably have the most justifiable
reason to do it
now would there be any republican
support for this voting rights bill
in the senate my understanding is
and again this is a topic that often
there's disagreement about i don't
believe that
there's a budget reconciliation argument
to be made for voting rights because
it's not
it's not a budget issue it's not a
spending issue although certainly some
of the initiatives cost
money maybe i'm wrong and you could do
voting rights
via budget reconciliation i've not read
anything so far that says you could
um and in the house the 800 page bill
passed basically along party lines
and it does a ton of stuff not all of
which republicans want much of which
some republicans
want none of this bill would create
minimum standards for states in terms of
how they must run
elections federal standards that states
must abide by
it would basically destroy a lot of the
voter id
proposals and laws in a variety of
different states
it would restore voting rights to former
felons period
not states will vote um as
as a referendum no it just it restores
voting rights to former felons
it puts in place requirements like
automatic voter registration
no excuse mail-in balloting which means
you don't need
a qualifying reason to
explain why you want to vote by mail you
can just say
i want to vote by mail and that's it and
a lot of these provisions are the exact
opposite of what republicans at the
state level are doing now it's important
to remember
many of the republicans in the senate
who would be voting on this bill
don't necessarily have the same
perspective or opinion on these issues
as the state republican legislators that
are working on
the ant on the voter suppression bills
uh but still i don't know that you get
any republican support for this the
other thing is on gerrymandering and
gerrymandering we've talked about
many times over the years this bill
that has passed the house and you know
we'll see what happens in the senate
would require states to use independent
commissions to draw congressional
districts
and right now this would significantly
hurt republicans you could imagine a
situation in the future
where it's democrats who have gotten to
draw the majority of the districts
and such a provision could hurt
democrats but remember that even
who gets to draw the districts aside
because
of the urban rural divide um
it favors republicans in in terms of
district drawing at a sort of core level
so that's a huge deal republicans know
that part of the reason they win some
districts
in purple states even in red states is
by drawing them in very particular ways
that we've exposed before
um so this is a this is a major deal if
it could be done
and what needs to be balanced by joe
biden and by democrats here in terms of
determining whether
this is the next thing that they want to
deal with is
number one the importance and the
urgency given that there's an election
now
in what two five minus twenty about 19
months we're 19 months from the midterms
and
if republicans just do what they're
doing in all of these different states
it will hurt the left in 2022 there's no
doubt so there's that urgency
there's the justification for using
enfranchisement
as a valid reason
to do something with the filibuster
maybe do away with
maybe just reform it mandate a talking
uh mandated talking filibuster
maybe make some other changes and
because
it could set up the possibility
of the infrastructure plan and of other
things
uh in the remainder of these first two
years of joe biden's term so that's the
gist of it i'm curious to hear from you
what do you want joe biden and democrats
focusing on next
should it be the tax reform plan which i
think politically is the most
um difficult at this point in time given
the circumstances with the pandemic and
economy which we'll talk about in a
moment
um should it be the infrastructure
spending plan
where there is maybe some more
republican support but they will be
opposed to much of it
or is it the voting rights expansion let
me know what you would like to see
joe biden and democrats tackle next one
of our sponsors is magic
spoon the breakfast cereal that tastes
just like the sugary
tasty delicious cereals we loved as kids
but without
the sugar and without the carbs magic
spoon
is sweet and delicious with zero grams
of sugar
13 grams of protein and only four
net carbs making it perfect for a low
carb or
keto diet this month magic spoon is
releasing
two amazing new flavors we're talking
about cookies and cream and maple waffle
only available for a limited time of
course you can still get cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter and
cinnamon build your
own variety pack our team has tried
every flavor
we keep asking them to send us more
magic spoon is as good as it sounds
magic spoon ships to the u.s and canada
and you'll get five dollars off and free
shipping when you go to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
i've put the link underneath this video